what is the connection in your mind to
the past what's your intention is this
about discovery
about archaeology like hands-on
archaeology about the viking era or is
this
more about like artisan craftsmanship in
the 21st century
to you what is the what's the sort of
point ah
i guess i'm always about the history or
are you about the future
or the or the present uh i like to have
a great time in my shop
uh investigating possibilities that uh
uh that might have possible techniques
that might have been used
in the past to get stuff done whenever
possible i will gladly have somebody
just tell me how to do it
and then i'll i'll do that you know i
enjoy simply doing things the way
they were done like when i was a kid i
was like fascinated by colonial
williamsburg because they're like
hardcore about just
doing everything the old way there i'm
not quite that hardcore if i can
hey i don't want to dress up
you know i i do want to get it done and
go on to the next thing i don't want it
to be a
hierarchical thing where i have to go
learn everything from some guy you know
it's like i want
to work through stuff and get a basic
familiarity with the
limitations and the discipline of the
material without
you know taking twice as long to do it
and you know
part of the reason is i want to
represent that sense of this is doable
to other people you know i'm trying to
open the doors
and make it accessible
and then you can also you can always
regress
the technique you could get the clothes
you can
sit on the ground with your aunt you
know your little anvil and you can make
this
and once you know how to do the acts the
other part would be sort of
in a way easier you know the the closing
the dressing up yeah
[Music]
you